mr. Zuckerberg is the CEO of Facebook
you're aware of my aunt Phyllis her
profile picture is an American Eagle in
a blue lives matter sure you're aware
correct yes let me call your attention
to something Phyllis recently posted on
your site
she wrote either everyone can say the
n-word or nobody can I vote for everyone
give any comment on that
reclaiming my time
Phyllis his brother recently got engaged
to a woman of Libyan descent and Phyllis
commented on the engagement post even my
own brother marrying a goat [ __ ] I I
don't know the answer to that off the
top my head are you aware that last
Thanksgiving my aunt Phyllis took a
particularly dangerous cocktail of
Chardonnay and percocet and went on your
site and claimed to be queuing on
I think lying is bad claiming my time
let me just call your attention to one
final thing mr. Zuckerberg recently
Phyllis posted a recipe for her holiday
cake which she clearly stole and the
only caption was Heil Hitler
it's it depends on the context that it
shows that some other things n Phyllis
is posted in my day kids shoveled snow
they didn't cut their dicks off to spite
Christ